hello everybody
uh my name is diego spiovic and uh it's
my honor to
be at the wolfram technology conference
this year
and what we'll do today is present
the developing of a computational essay
specifically on the history of the eb2
bombing in the
united kingdom
so the uh the topic of
writing essays was created by our friend
here called
michelle de montaigne in the 16th
century so
essays come from the french essay which
is basically a trial
and he covered all kinds of aspects of
things he observed the inner thoughts he
had etc
so we come forward the five centuries
and we we see steve and walter and
launch an initiative which is called the
computational essay which not only
brings together the text and
pictures and whatnot but also
computational
into into the mix that allows
you to reach an audience and the
audience to be able to explore just more
than
a static picture and text
so what we wanted to cover is the uh the
vengeance weapon the v2
this was the first ballistic missile uh
developed
and one of the interesting things about
it it started in 1929
the development because due to the
versace peace treaty
the germans were not allowed to develop
any more
medium or long-term long-range
artillery rounds so as
necessity is always the mother of
inventions the
ordinance group in germany started
investigating you know the work of god
art in the united states and some german
theorists around the missile technology
that
would be feasible to create a liquid
fuel
rocket to be used as a weapon
and so that was the initial thought that
was in 1929 and they had to go through
all the
technology uh issues to to make this
happen and hitler took
that idea an advantage as a response to
what was
the strategic bombing initiative um
the allies would go and and attack
the main cities of germany as
what was called as an euphemism area
bombing of precision bombing but
basically was
uh back then the technology on bombs was
not efficient enough to go and destroy
actually buildings so the second the
thing that was
done was basically uh the terrorizing
and
killing of uh workers trying to
demoralize
uh the the population and this was done
by both sides of the war it's not
exclusive from the allies it was all
based on a
on a theory which is called strategic
bombing
so they it was major destruction that
germany suffered along the war
and hitler wanted to use once this
technology was developed
as a revenge on the allies
the uh the use of e2 was not limited
only to england which was around 1500
missiles that were launched during the
um
this phase of the war but also in europe
mainly against
belgium now the the use of the v2 was
completely different as anything
that had been observed before before you
know
when you had the uh the bombers coming
in or even the b1
bomb you know that could be observed and
you know sirens would go off that would
give them
they would give people time enough to
try to get to a bomb shelter
and the um and the allies or whoever was
there you know they could detect the
incoming uh bombers
with greater technology and some
precautionary
measures could be taken that none of
that would exist
once we enter into the uh space age
the rockets will come in at 3 000 miles
per hour and you know based on
on the recounts of witnesses
they would be looking at a building the
building will just
disappear explode then you will hit the
actual explosion and then the
the sound effect of the broken
sound barrier uh at the beginning people
were not
did not understand what's going on they
thought they were sabotagers that
were exploding bombs around the city
now um this news were completely silent
around these attacks uh for two purposes
what you know the this type of missile
which we will see later
that was known by by the allies that
what
what they this consisted of um
it's a ballistic so there was it's it's
being sent
towards the target but there's no
feedback unless you are
in england to see exactly where the
bombs fell so
the best way to not give any information
to the enemy was to silence
the the news about these types of
attacks
and the second thing any news that were
given to the press
was given were given uh fake news
basically stating that the rockets have
gone way beyond their target
so with the hope that the enemy will
recalibrate their launching of rockets
and make them fall
before the big city now
to do the analysis and bring the data
into
mathematica i found this website which
lists all the
rocket strikes this was compiled by the
ministry of defense after the war it's
in this
official document heir 24126
and the first issue that i
went through was the issue of the map
reference as you can see it has this
strange code
well that strange code is the cassini
grid and basically
the military mass back in between 1927
and 1936
where based on this grid it has a
major grid of 500
250 kilometers i guess and each small
box is of 100 times 100 kilometers and
then the numbers
is indication of the northings from the
southwest corner
and the eastings
so one of the first things that um
we could do and i saw this functionality
from arnold he did a twitch
on using web execute is use
um the where the um
calculator that it's in a web page to
extract this information so for example
what i'll do is i'll take these two
coordinate systems
and have a mathematica take control go
to that webpage
and read back the coordinates
those coordinates have been put back and
graphed
on a geographic map
so that way we could pre-process all the
v2 impacts and those were placed in
github
and therefore we could actually now
recover them
by importing the data from github
we can do very basic uh analysis just to
show
a little bit about uh the data set we
can
look and see that the first bombs were
in in september 8
1944 44 and the last ones to
be launched was in march 27th 1945
and this is a timeline of the different
explosions and different places
where they fell now
one of the interesting cons things about
the war is the
this was a scientific war and the
british had what was called the
scientific
intelligence office and
these people were collecting information
about what was going on in the german
camp the first thing that came in was
called the oslo report
and what happened was
um a person um
approached via mail the
military attache in oslo stating that he
had a lot of information to provide
the allies on military technology that's
been
that was being developed by the germans
so this is if you're interested in this
change the announcement of the bbc
uh shortwave stating that was
transmitted in german stating a
keyword saying you know hello from
london or something along those lines
the message was received and this person
left
a box with seven pages of uh
of information that covered from radar
even he gave some valves which was a
a proximity switch for um some
development that was being done on
missile technology surface-to-air
technology to
explode weapons you know once they were
reaching
close to a bomber um now
in in this book which is called most
secret war
it's very interesting that uh the the
discussions that were having had between
the scientific
intelligence unit and the normal uh
intelligence country intelligence from
great britain saying that
this must be a planting and whatnot and
but at the end the information was too
good and this is the first place where
pena penemunde the location where it was
being developed was mentioned
then there were other databases so this
is
uh human intelligence captured generals
um there were
you know people that were captured you
know would talk between them and
and some some people were mentioning um
the uh the existence of this weapon
um then you had a intercepts
of ultra which was the enigma machine
that would talk about um
about ready radar units being moved east
for some testing and then
the uh the germans had foreign workers
on
on penny moon and at least two people
from luxembourg the
luxembourgers would uh report back
through the
resistance uh what they saw so for
example this one is
a a little micro film that
was received then from dr wagner
sorry schweichner and which he he made a
detailed drawing of what he observed
that was being done in pennamonda
and that went through the belgian
resistance all the way to
to to england and based on that
information that they received
recognizance was sent and this is the
first image
in which this was a stereo photograph in
which you see in
the sea it's the first time that they
recognize
um what looks to be a missile
and based on the measures they need they
could actually start
seeing what size the um
the missile was about so based on the
recognizance of
the of the allies they decided what to
launch what was called the operation
hydra
and that was sending the raf to bomb
penemond
and destroyed installations uh what they
decided to focus
focus on was on the dorms
with the idea is that uh you know if
they kill the scientists and the people
working on the project it could actually
delay
uh much more um the effort
and you know the place was spawned so
they had to actually move all the way to
poland
uh let's see if this works yeah which uh
to blisna which is 430 miles away
southwest and um
you know this was known and intercepted
so
they started sending a recognizance over
there they
find a creator there were some
still some tests done in the baltic one
falls
uh into sweden uh it was remote
controlled and the
the person who was doing the remote
control lost
lost the um control of the
missile and exploded but uh the a lot of
electronics fell
in sweden and though those were
recovered two british intelligence
officers went there and
exchanged favors with the sweden the
swedish people and and took a lot of the
the electronics back to investigate um
the polish intelligence was uh sending
information about what they observed
they were really really fast
on getting to the craters much faster
than the germans so
a lot of uh material was collected from
the debris
it was actually it's it's uh interesting
they tell the story about uh
getting someone driving a bike for 200
kilometers and getting extracted on a
dakota plane
uh with a lot of uh pieces from
the the site and um landed in
in england and you know when someone
wanted to approach with the knife would
take him away they had to get someone
that spoke polish to tell him to uh
that you know these were the good guys
and he could give the uh
all the all the data they collected
there
uh blexley park kept collecting
information on
on on this initiative and for example
they
they put the code that they were talking
about key components on this program and
got
getting serial numbers and based on
analysis on serial numbers they could
estimate
what the number of rockets were in stock
back then another interesting piece of
information is that
as the soviets were moving west
lisna falls to the soviets the
british intelligence tries to go there
and ask them to
if they can take away the materials that
were there they said no no you can't
take it
we'll send that to you and that never
arrived
everything was complicated by the
soviets
in the meantime the allies are already
in in france
so as they advance they capture in
normandy a series of maps that he
pointed
on the storage sites where the and the
launch sites were
they were in the french territories and
so that was taken care of by the
by the aviation and as
prisoners failed they started getting to
more information there was a lot of wild
estimates by the experts on how much the
missile
waited how much um what was the payload
and with the information from the
prisoners they that was uh
finally put to an end and they knew that
it was within 8 tons
and an estimated range of 200 miles and
the first bombs fall on september the
8th
so with the data that we were looking at
we can use geographics to um
to basically pinpoint where the
v2 bombs fell in england and you can see
that they're concentrating into
two areas one is london east of london
and the other one is norwich we can use
com
cluster component analysis to estimate
which bonds were dedicated to which area
by k means the issue of norwich is
one of the aspects of the campaign and
that was done on the blitz too it was
not only in
london the main city that was born but
also historical sites that had a meaning
to the um through the english like
canterbury cambridge oxford
and other places from a different side
we were i was able to
obtain the um launching sites
so this chart graphs the different
places
where the um b2s were launched from
and the good thing about the wall from
language is that we can explore then
knowing that it's 200 miles the autonomy
of the missile
okay which were the potential sites from
where these missiles were launched
towards england
so this little piece of code allows us
to
graph and explore that information
this is a list of the different launch
sites so we click on there it will show
you the exact
locations and which which times these
launch sites were operational
now let's turn a little bit and do a
little bit of physics
uh high sc high school physics
right so um if we look at uh
the first launches were coming from a
town called basanar
north east of the hague and the first
two
bombs as we mentioned fell in chiswick
and epping
which is around 200 miles away so given
that this was a ballistic
missile mainly basically the
the whole fuel was consumed and then it
just went on free fall
let's see if our high school
physics works so the first thing is okay
um we're gonna ignore the coriolis
effect
you know we're more or less in the same
latitude so that'd be fine and we
will have to correct based on the earth
rotation
so we know that um based on the latitude
in which
vasiners is the earth at that point
uh turns eastwards at 366
meters per second right
and the distance between vasiner and the
first of the bombs
it was 300 328 000 meters
we can then solve the ballistic equation
the set of equations uh taking
taking in consideration the earth
gravity and we get
to that the initial velocity of the
v2 rocket should be around 1552
meters per second this is a book that uh
first page
of the book written by general
dardenberg who he was in charge of the
v2 program
and so in his book he mentions
different technical aspects of the bomb
so we can see here that the
maximum velocity of trajectory was
around
1600 meters per second
so pretty close to uh what they taught
us in high school
which is pretty neat
okay so uh
this is a timeline of the
attacks at the beginning these are the
number of uh
rockets that fell in england
per week and at the beginning of the
campaign the the main bottleneck that
the
germans had was the actual
manufacturing of of the liquid oxygen
they had a restriction in capacity on
that which
they could not fire the rockets
fast enough
and here we can use the wealth language
to
for example give an animation of
the weekly launches
against the uk
now the
one of the things that uh what discussed
in the war was
by by some people that you know the the
attacks were mostly on poor people and
the bombs were not
falling randomly so one of the papers
that you could actually find on the
internet was the application of a
poisson distribution
uh by rd clark to see if the actual
bombs
the uh the destruction done by the b1
bombs
was truly random or not so we'll do the
same study with the b2
i was happy today to see that uh goisia
and
eduardo are working on special
statistics and that would have come
handy instead of
the procedure i worked below so the
first thing uh
to do was to graph all the bombings
where they fell and did a smooth kernel
distribution with it
you can see that the the mode is east of
london
uh the center of london it's uh in
lambda
that's where it so it's a little bit to
the east
so we know that no doubt that the the
center is
east of the city but is it clustered or
not so
we'll follow the same path that uh
this person did and with drawing a 24 by
24 kilometers
uh grid we basically end up counting how
many
how many impacts were per area
so here we have a matrix we see where
they fall and then we can do
counts and see how many uh
rectangle had no bombing one two etc
and we can find the distribution and we
can compare those numbers to
the actual numbers um of uh v2 counts
versus what would be the estimation
based on the poisson distribution
and it's pretty close so if we run
another
hypothesis testing we cannot
reject the idea that this is basically
they fall in a random
pattern around the density lambda
so just to close um
if you would like to write your own
computational essays there is now a
resource function if you
process this
this resource function it will open a
computational essay template that you
can fill in
and and write your um
your essay and you know you can submit
it and it will be
posted in what's called the notebook
archive
so
if you go to this webpage you will see
many contributions for a lot of
people around any type of topic
so it's very interesting to see and i
hope
you you do have fun writing your own
computational essays
and just as a closing
here are some um some
recommendations if you're interested on
the battle of which between the british
intelligence and the germans
this book called most secret war
takes you through through the um
the whole process of uh of the
investigation on
from the radar technology ultra etc also
you can see
the major generals account on the
development of the
v2 bomb from the german side it's
fascinating both dornenberg and von
braun who work with him
were extracted from austria to the west
in what was called the operation
paperclip by the cia
and actually they work together to
develop the
missile program in the united states so
as a final word it's a lot of fun to be
able to use a computational essay to
explore any topic
that might be of your choice including
history
so hope to see
you writing some pieces of your own
thank you so much
and i'll be seeing if there's any
questions
sorry i i opened some extra windows on
my screen so i need to see if i can get
to
i lost the path to pathway so please
contact me if you have any questions
through uh
through possible it was a pleasure uh
sharing this story with you i hope you
enjoyed it
thank you